[موسيقى]
في عام 2003 وفي مثل هذه الايام ولدت قناه
العربيه
ولدت في وقت استثنائي
العالم كان يغلي والمنطقه تمر بتحولات
كبرى
ولدت العربيه في الوقت المناسب
فكانت الصوت المختلف للعقل في مرحله سادت
فيها الخطابات المتطرفه
وسيطره فيها الاعلام الدعائي والشعبوي
لقد دخلت العربيه المشهد وقامت بالتحول
الكبير في الساحتين الاعلاميه والفكريه
واذا تاملنا حقيقه ما فعلته العربيه خلال
عشرين عاما نرى كيف
رسخت قيم الصحافه الحقيقيه
تبنت الموضوعيه ولم تخلط بين الراي والخبر
سعت الى المصداقيه بكل الطرق حتى لو اغضبت
البعض
كان من السهل عليها ان تحرك الغرائز
او ان تتلاعب عواطف الناس كسبا للجماهيريه
ولكنها لم تفعل
المهنيه كانت وجهتها الاساسيه التي لم تحد
عنها منذ عشرين عاما وحتى هذا اليوم
كان ذلك تحديا كبيرا نجحت فيه رغم العوائق
والصعوبات
كما لعبت العربيه دورا محوريه في معركه
التنوير ومواجهه دعوات الكراهيه والعنف
والجهل
لقد تعرضت لهجمات من جماعات وشخصيات
واحزاب وجهاد تعرضها في القيم والافكار
والتصورات ورات فيها تهديدا لسيطرتها
ونفوذها على العقول والقلوب
تمسكت العربيه في خطها ومضت في طريقها
واثبتت مكانها ومكانتها وبعد عشرين عاما
ونحن نجتمع الان في عيدها من الصعب ان
نتخيل كيف سيبدو المشهد الاعلامي والفكري
خلال العقدين الماضيين لو لم تكنوا
العربيه موجوده وركن اساسيا فيه
لقد استطاعت قناه العربيه بكوادرها من
الصحفيين والفنيين والمراسلين والمحترفين
استيعاب التغيرات
والتفاعل مع التطورات التي تشهدها صناعه
الاعلام
لم تسجد نفسها في الماضي لتعيش على
الامجاد فالعربيه مصممه منذ البدايات على
الانطلاق نحو المستقبل
رحبت الافكار الجديده والتقنيات الحديثه
وتوسعت للتحول اليوم الى شبكه اعلاميه
عربيه متعدده الفروع هي الاهم في المنطقه
انا فخور اليوم
بالعمل جنبا الى جنب مع زميلات وزملاء من
خيره الكفاءات والطاقات من كل الجنسيات
التي تضمن تدفق الاخبار الجاده والموثوقه
والقصص الهادفه
استذكر معهم التضحيات التي بذلوها
والمخاطر التي واجهوها في مناطق عديده من
العالم ثمنا للحقيقه
وباسمهم جميعا نتوجه بالشكر والتقدير
لاعضاء مجلس اداره شبكه العربيه وفي
مقدماتهم الشيخ وليد الابراهيم رئيس مجلس
اداره المجموعه على ما يبدلونه من دعم
ومتابعه ومسانده لتوفير اسباب النجاح الذي
تحقق
انا مدير محظوظ نعم قلتها للزميلات
والزملاء في العربيه واقولها اليوم في هذه
المناسبه لانني محاط بنخبه رائعه تعمل على
مدار الساعه في غرف التحرير وفي الميادين
المختلفه ايمانا برساله العربيه بان تكون
مثال المهنيه ومناره للتنوير
ولتسمحوا لي في هذه المناسبه انا اتوجه
جميع اتوجه باسمكم جميعا فالشكر والتقدير
الى كل من تعاقب على اداره العربيه وتحمل
الضغوط والمصاعب من اجل نجاحها مهمه عسيره
قادوها بكل اقتدار
نعم انا مدير محظوظ
لانني معكم في الرياض عاصمه المستقبل
وقبله المؤسسات العالميه الكبرى حيث تبث
العربيه نشراتها وبرامجها من استديوهاتها
وتستمر في توسعها
والياذن لمعالي وزير الاعلام وسعاده رئيس
مجلس الاداره
بالاعلان من هنا من الرياض باطلاق اذاعه
العربيه اف ام
لتكون الاقرب دوما والاقدر على استجابات
والاقدر على الاستجابه الاحتياجات الجمهور
المختلفه ولنكون بذلك المؤسسه الاعلاميه
التي تصل خدماتها الى مختلف الفئات
والشرائح حيثما كانوا
واجدد الوعد لموظفينا في المقام الاول
ولمؤسسهنا ولمشاهدينا بان نستمر معا لنكون
دوما في المقدمه وفي الختام اتذكر
الزميلات والزملاء الذين فقدناهم وخسرناهم
او من تعرض منهم لاصابات بالغه وتكريبا
لهم
ولذكراهم ومن اجل كل مشاهده ومشاهد محب
لشبكه العربيه في كل مكان اقول
اننا سائرون على مبادئنا الاساسيه في ان
نكون اقرب للحقيقه وان تكون العربيه ان
تعرف اكثر شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]